[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAIME GREEN: Please
welcome Lizz Winstead.
[APPLAUSE]
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Thank you.
JAIME GREEN: Lizz Winstead is
the co-creator and former head
writer of "The Daily
Show" and co-founder
of Air America Radio.
She's the author of
"Lizz Free Or Die"
and her latest project is
Lady Parts Justice League.
Lizz, thank you for joining us.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Thank
you for having me.
JAIME GREEN: So I
made a note to myself
and I was coming up
with what to talk about.
I was like, before we dive
into everything I'll just ask,
like a nice opening question.
Maybe something based
on the news of the day.
And then I was like,
that's a terrible idea.
That doesn't sound like
a pleasant way to--
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Well
the news of the day,
it's like the news
of the moment.
So I don't know when
this goes out but--
JAIME GREEN: Yeah I
haven't looked at twitter
in the last five minutes.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: There
will be 900 other things
that will be toppling that.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: And
basically, just
say, garbage fire, and move on.
[LAUGHTER]
Just garbage fire.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah, all right.
So with that out of the way--
[LAUGHTER]
Garbage fire.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Garbage right.
JAIME GREEN: Now, what is
Lady Parts Justice League?
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Well.
It is, we're a nonprofit
that is made up
of comedians, writers, graphic
designers, shooters, editors.
And it's a bunch of
people that decided
there is so much
horrible news happening
in the landscape of
reproductive rights and justice.
And when you turn
on your television
or you talk to other
friends who care about this,
oftentimes they think they
know and they don't know.
They know about one third of
what's actually happening.
And so we wanted
to do two things.
We wanted to make
videos that expose
the politicians and
the laws and just
the cretins in general who
are assaulting the access
to reproductive health care.
And then, the other
cool thing we do,
which is sort of my
favorite thing that we do,
is we are a band that
is a combination of,
kind of like, let's
call it a USO Show
and Habitat for Humanity.
So--
Actually today we are launching.
We're doing a 16-week tour that
we're just announcing today.
We're going for eight weeks.
We're going to 16 cities.
Starting June 2 in the
Deep South and the Midwest.
We'll do a comedy music show.
And then we're going to
do outreach to clinics.
We're going to like, help build
fences, do gardening for them.
Bring them like, food,
take them out for drinks,
anything to sort of
normalize their work.
And to sort of do
an emotional reset
on what it means to be a
provider because I think--
I started this in 2012 where I
just did my own little comedy
tour of clinics.
And when I talked to providers
and maybe the receptionist
or even like a nurse,
they would say to me,
thank you for coming here.
No one ever comes.
And that just struck a
chord with me so profoundly
that I thought, I don't really
have to adjust my life at all.
I'm basically just still
doing shows, making videos,
but I'm honing in on a subject
that I care deeply about.
That I feel like doesn't
get enough attention.
So that's what it is.
That's what we do.
JAIME GREEN: That's
pretty awesome.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Thanks!
JAIME GREEN: One of the things
you mentioned is gardening.
And I actually hadn't
heard about this before.
Can you talk a
little bit about--
like, we know what a fence at an
abortion clinic would help do.
Can you talk about the garden?
LIZZ WINSTEAD:
But you don't know
what a garden at an
abortion clinic does?
[LAUGHTER]
Well, let me tell you,
because it does many things.
JAIME GREEN: And
it's more than just--
LIZZ WINSTEAD: And they don't
bury the fetus is there,
contrary to the news from
Breitbart and alternative
facts.
[LAUGHTER]
So a lot of times when we--
because we contact
the clinics in advance
to see what they need.
And they always say things
like, it's like an orphanage
sometimes.
It's like, just, you
know, if you have cupcakes
or if you could just come by.
It's like, no, seriously.
So we bring cupcakes for lunch.
And then we sort of
assess what's happening.
And so a good example
of what we do is,
we went to North
Carolina because there's
an organization that was
called 40 Days For Life that
was trying to plan a sneak
attack on this clinic.
Well we do some infiltrating
of website and places
and found out about this.
So we decided to go
down there and preempt
this massive bust that came.
And so, protesters
oftentimes will stand
on property anywhere they can.
And the clinic doesn't
even see, like,
a hole that could be filled.
So we looked at where the
protesters were standing
and realized, you know, if we
just planted a gigantic holly
bush-- and if you know anything
about holly it's really
prickly--
that's tall enough.
That is just one space that
a protester can't stand
and scream into the clinic.
So we do that.
Sometimes it's like
when you build a fence,
you just have to do some
gardening around it.
So it can be strategic
planting or it can be--
you know what?
This is the place
people go to the doctor.
It should look nice.
And it should feel normal.
And so our big thing is
to bust stigma, you know,
get rid of the shame.
Let doctors feel like they
can live in the light.
And have the staff and
people and patients that go,
feel like they're
doing what they
are doing, which
is accessing one
of the panoply of
medical services
that somebody might
need in their lifetime.
So making it normal.
Making abortion great again.
Yes!
[LAUGHTER]
That's what we do.
JAIME GREEN: Let's, I'd love
to back up and just look
at how you got here.
So we back all the way up.
It's my understanding
that you grew up
in a Catholic home in the
Midwest, is that right?
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Yes, so
everyone is super psyched
about my choices in life.
[LAUGHTER]
JAIME GREEN: Yeah, so, did you--
was there some like,
grand feminist awakening?
LIZZ WINSTEAD: There was
a couple grand feminists
awakening.
One was that, much
to the luck of me,
I'm the youngest of
five kids in my family,
my parents are super Catholic.
Like, not like this
Pope Catholic, like--
JAIME GREEN: A couple
Popes ago Catholic?
LIZZ WINSTEAD: A couple
Popes ago Catholic.
[LAUGHTER]
Because this Pope is
sort of awesome, right?
I mean, he's kind of like,
I always look at this Pope
and I think, he's kind of like
a guy who was in a crappy band
but now he's having an
amazing solo career.
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
So it's like-- and then
when they play the old hits,
you're like, shut up
with the old hits.
Ain't nobody got time
for your old hits.
So it was, it was one
of those things where--
There was a couple things.
One, I'd never been--
and this is going to
just sound horrible
in the context of what
we've talked about already--
I was never driven to have kids.
It's just never been
my thing, right?
And so even as a
little kid, like,
I'm the person
that loved Barbie.
And so-- because
Barbie had a boyfriend.
And she had her own
house and a car.
And like, I didn't
care about the boobs
or even that she couldn't stand.
The fact of the matter is,
she was like, independent.
Put her in the car,
there she goes, you know?
So I really liked
that in a doll.
And I-- and even my
mom said, you know,
you never play with
the things I give you.
And it was like, well, you
gave me like a baby doll.
And then you gave me an iron.
And then you gave
me an ironing board.
And then you gave me a stove.
And it's like,
basically everything
that you sob at night over,
you gave me as like, a toy.
[LAUGHTER]
It's like, where's the
inflatable drunk of a husband
toy?
Because why don't we just
round this whole life out?
[LAUGHTER]
And so, I needed to
make money as a kid.
You know, for candy and
lipgloss, or whatever we were
raising money for at that time.
And I saw all the boys
being altar boys, right?
And I was like, well
that's a way to make money.
They were like raking it in.
Serving at weddings
and funerals.
You know, apparently you didn't
get paid for like, the Sunday
Mass thing.
So when I went to the
priest and I said,
I want to be an altar boy,
the priest freaked out.
And said-- pulled out of his
ass, literally-- he goes,
well you can't because--
And then I can see,
you know how adults
go like this, when they like,
don't have anything to say.
He was like, doing that.
And he was like, well you
know, it's called altar boy.
So, obviously.
I was like, well-- and I
wasn't trying to be a jerk.
I was just trying to get to
make money at the weddings.
That's what I wanted to do.
And so I said, well, you know,
you can call me an altar girl.
And then he was like,
well, you know, you should
you should write the Archbishop.
[LAUGHTER]
Just passing the buck, right?
So I got a petition and
I wrote the Archbishop.
And like, not long after I wrote
the Archbishop, unfortunately
during Lent the Archbishop
had too much to drink
and plowed into the
wall of a 7-Eleven.
So the Archbishop had his
own problems to deal with
and wasn't concerned about
letting me be an altar boy.
But at that point I just was
like, I had this little case
of like, I don't get it.
I don't get why I'm a girl
and I can't be an altar boy.
This is dumb.
And so there was just instances
in life in general where--
if there was a clear
explanation like,
don't climb a tree
barefoot because that's
going to cut your feet.
I'm like oh, that seems like
good advice from an adult.
But if there was no real
explanation, I was just mad.
And because I was a curious kid.
And so there was just
a series of that shit
that started happening.
And then, somebody said--
you know, I got cynical.
And then I would
be a little snarky.
And then somebody said,
you should try stand-up.
When I was in college.
And I thought-- and this was
a part that really got me.
And I looked at the
landscape of stand-ups,
and sure there was
women doing it.
There was like, Joan Rivers.
And there was like,
Phyllis Diller.
But I didn't see myself.
I was like a punk-rock,
23-year-old kid,
and I didn't see my world
coming out of anybody's mouths.
And then I saw George Carlin.
And so, it took a
dude to convince me
that I could do stand-up.
Which was a problem.
[LAUGHTER]
Like, the fact that
I did not see myself.
And now it's so cool to see all
of these really amazing women
doing it.
But yeah.
So I started out, you
know, just doing it.
And I would do like,
I wasn't particularly
political at the time, you know?
I would have jokes
like, if you ever
play monopoly with bald guys
they always pick the hat.
You know, stupid.
[LAUGHTER]
That joke doesn't even
deserve that much laughter.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm not even kidding.
That was really nice
of you to do that.
You know, and then I would
talk about gender and equity
or, you know, dating.
But it really wasn't--
I cared about politics.
I was very, like, I read
about it and I knew about it,
but I didn't bring it to stage.
And then-- I guess if there
was like, the true comedy,
how did it change everything?
It would have to be--
oh my God.
I can swear here, right?
And stuff?
JAIME GREEN: You have been.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Oh.
[LAUGHTER]
JAIME GREEN: So--
LIZZ WINSTEAD:
Guess I should have
asked about 10 minutes ago.
I had moved to New York in 1991.
And somebody set me
up on a blind date.
And-- do you remember those?
They were-- it happened.
[LAUGHTER]
Like, they don't exist now
because you just hook up
with people you regret later.
[LAUGHTER]
On your phone.
But there was a thing.
And it was like,
it never was the--
you know, I've got
a person for you.
Actually, you don't.
But I would go because
I'm from the Midwest.
And when someone says, you
know, I have the person for you,
you're like, all right
well that's nice.
I'll go do that because
you invited me, right?
So the guy shows up at my house.
And, you know, like
what's the plan?
I'm like, well maybe do you
want to go see La Dolce Vita?
I'd never seen it
on a big screen.
And he looks at me and he's
like, isn't that, like,
in black and white?
And I was like, oh man.
[LAUGHTER]
And if that wasn't
bad enough, he
is wearing a Yankees hat
and a Yankees satin jacket.
[LAUGHTER]
And I have a theory
about guys that
wear more than one
piece of sports clothing
at the same time.
And that is that they
won't go down on you.
[LAUGHTER]
I believe this is
a proven thing.
I just-- So I'm like, this
is like, a double whammy.
But I'm going to do it
because I'm from the Midwest
and I'm nice.
So we go to the movie.
And then the guy--
this is going somewhere, people.
The story, I swear God.
I know you're like,
she is prattling on.
And the guy keeps falling asleep
and then rubbing his satin
jacket up and down my arm.
And I'm just like,
eating my popcorn
and like, getting
more and more rageful.
To the point where I was like,
fighting internally, my like,
I'm real nice.
And I fucking hate this guy.
I'm real-- [NOISES]
So finally I just took my
greasy hand and I just like,
purposefully hit his
jacket to wake him up.
And then I felt horribly.
I just felt horrible
that I actually
wrecked his jacket on purpose.
And then, so I had to
make up for it by saying,
wake up let's go have a drink!
Continuing this night!
[LAUGHTER]
So we go to a bar that he knew
about because he watched sports
there.
But on this night,
there was no sports
on because it was the night
of the first Gulf War.
And if you'll remember, you
won't because you probably
weren't born, but
[LAUGHTER]
It was the first
time that America
watched, like, a war like unfold
in their living rooms, live.
And they had replaced like,
the regular anchors on CNN
with like, handsome people.
And there was that green light.
And people were very, I'm
Dirk Sturdy on the roof.
And the bombs.
And it was like--
I just watched it.
And I wasn't trying to wax
philosophical, I was just
taking in thinking, are
they reporting on a war
or trying to sell me a war?
And about two minutes
later the date was like,
this is really awesome.
And I was like, this
is a fucking problem.
And so I just sort of
started from that moment
on, like, paying more
attention to the media.
Seeing the information
that like, I was getting.
Seeing what kind of, like, are
they just reporting the press
releases from the White House?
Like, what can I talk about?
What can I not?
You know.
And so my comedy act started
changing dramatically,
talking a lot about not only
America's role in the world,
politics in general, but
also the media's role in how
all of that played out.
And when I realized, as we
started getting ourselves
into these big, manipulative
wars, that the media was
as complicit as any.
I mean, literally
when your network
is reporting on the
news and doing reports
about the negotiations
of whether
or not we're going to go to war.
And then when they
go to commercial
there's a giant graphic that
says, countdown to the war.
You're like, are we negotiating?
Or do you know
something I don't know?
Because you literally have a
theme song and a graphic that
says, we're counting
down to the war, not,
we're negotiating to see if
we're going to go to war.
So I did a couple
of one-woman shows.
And then I was like,
trying to figure out
what I was going to do next.
And I worked on Jon Stewart's
first talk show as a producer.
And when that got canceled,
a small group of that team
was asked by our executives
who had moved over
to Comedy Central, if we
wanted to launch a show that
responded to the world.
And I was like, oh my
God, are you kidding me?
I am like, a person
who can barely type.
And I've never run any show.
And all I do is
spout out my mouth.
But yes, it's kind of my dream.
And so "The Daily
Show" was born.
And created by a whole bunch of
people who had a lot of passion
for exposing hypocrisy
and being funny.
And well, you know, there it is.
It's been on the
air for 20 years.
[LAUGHTER]
It did good.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
Something I'm curious
about in your work
before "The Daily Show,"
"The Daily Show" and after.
It's-- you know, you said that
they wanted you guys to create
a show that was responding to--
LIZZ WINSTEAD: The news.
JAIME GREEN: The news, yeah.
And so you use comedy to
talk about politics and world
events.
But in "The Daily Show"
and your other work
it's also using politics
and world events
as the fodder for comedy--
LIZZ WINSTEAD: As the-- yeah.
And also as the fodder
for the media, you know.
It can't be stressed
enough how much
the media has played a role
through all of this, you know?
How much cable news-- and
as it bloated out more--
has been complicit in all of it.
So, yes.
But I think the problem
that I faced is that--
You know, after we
launched "The Daily Show"
and then I left and I went on
to do some other smaller shows.
I did one on Oxygen
that was like, actually
a really funny show
that was six episodes.
It was like "The
Daily Show" meets
"Colbert" meets Kathie
Lee and whatever,
whoever those women are, it
was like, that kind of format.
And then we launched
Air America Radio.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: And even
that, as out there as it
was, or as much freedom
as we had, should I say,
it was still part of an entity
that was a corporate entity.
And the bottom line is,
in all of these projects,
I say this a lot but
it's true, I felt a lot
like an anger fluffer.
Like I would just
get people riled up.
But it wasn't my job to
have a call to action.
So if I can be funny and
give people information.
And they're like,
what do I do now?
And I'm like, I don't
know, I'm just a comedian.
I'm just the writer.
I wanted to be
able to give people
a place to channel the energy.
And so that's why
I wrote a book.
And then after I
wrote the book, I
decided that I really wanted
to take all of the things
I care about, comedy social
justice, making a difference
through comedy and actually
then hitting the ground
and doing tangible work.
And the only way to do
that was to start a thing.
And I started this thing.
JAIME GREEN: And
so that brings us
to this thing, which is perfect.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: This
thing, this thing here.
Yeah.
JAIME GREEN: Yes.
So- because something I wonder
about with the lack of call
to actions, is, you know,
you'll see on Twitter
and social media nowadays
like, people saying like,
look at this.
This is happening.
This is not normal.
Don't be complacent.
And I'm like, I'm not.
What do I do?
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Right.
JAIME GREEN: So what sort of--
how are you moving from just
raising people's awareness
of what's going on to actually
giving them tools or helping
them figure out
what they can do?
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Well I
think one of the things
that's important for me
is, A, figuring out--
when you sign up to volunteer
for us, for example, we ask you
how much time you have to give?
What your skill set is?
And then we can make that work.
Also like, for example,
on the women's march.
It's a-- we had an activist
fair that we sponsored.
Where we had 15 tables.
It was right off the march path
at a hotel called the UN Hotel.
We did it here, in
New York, because I
felt like, I don't want to go
to D.C. I want to stay here
because a lot of the
policies that people
are going to be affected
by-- those people live here.
You know, we have strong
immigrant population.
Strong undocumented population.
Women.
You know, all of it.
And so we had 15
different organizations
representing 15 different ways
that you could participate,
whether it was environmental,
racial justice, you know,
whatever it was.
And sort of our
rule was, your group
has to be able to let
people like, get in there
and do some work.
You know, not just sign
up, not just give us money,
like, because I think
that's important.
And so what we do is, for
example, if you wanted
to volunteer with us, there's a
myriad of things you could do.
You can-- we sign,
we send postcards
to clinics throughout the year.
And then we have,
four times a year
we have orchestrated
postcard programs
where sending them love really
makes all the difference
in the world.
So, you know, that's a
simple thing we can do.
We help legislatively, like
everybody else does, where
you can sign this petition.
For example, a-- this is crazy.
So we've worked with
a clinic in Ohio.
We went to Ohio to help
out during the Republican
Convention because part of
the activities for the RNC
was to go protest a clinic.
They had, I mean, insane.
So this clinic that we had
befriended, and now work with,
someone stole their fence.
A psychotic person
had been, like,
chipping away at their fence.
And just stole their fence.
They came to work and
their fence was gone.
So we were able to do a Facebook
Live event where we went on
and we said, this clinic
had their fence stolen,
they need $10,000 to do it.
Here's the origin story.
We put the origin story
out, we told the thing,
and the clinic said, you
guys just raised us money
to buy a new fence.
In five hours.
So when we pay attention to the
needs of each of these places,
we can specifically tailor.
If we need graphic
design work, if a clinic
needs graphic design work
for something they're doing.
If you want to
help us with meals.
I mean, this tour
that we're going on,
we're launching this tour today.
You know, it's like, we're
launching a fundraiser with it.
Because we need a van.
We're taking 11 bodies
to go and grow community
in 16 different cities where
a clinic is desperately
needing support that will
last long after we show up.
So, one of the things
that's really kind of cool
is, we created a system
where we'll do a comedy music
show in a town, we
have a talk back
with the provider and
maybe somebody who
runs an escort program or
somebody who runs that abortion
fund in that state.
After they laugh and
hear music they'll
hear a Q&A, that's like this,
they'll be less questions,
and they can sign up
to help the clinic out.
So does that mean you bring
cupcakes four times a year?
Does that mean you help
them with hot breakfast
on the Saturday morning when
there's a lot of clinics?
Does that mean you sign
up to escort yourself?
Does that mean that
you get together,
and then you can
reach out to us,
and say, we're trying to
figure out a creative action.
Can you help us?
And we're like, sure, you know.
We've helped people with like,
everybody wear hospital gowns
and go sit in your state
legislator's office.
And just wait for
your Pap smear.
And they just sit
there and wait.
And when they come out and
say, what are you doing here?
We're like, well we're
here for a pap smear
since you absolutely
know how my body works.
I'd like you to actually
give me a Pap smear.
[LAUGHTER]
And so, you know,
helping people get
creative with their local
actions is really great.
And so we are
constantly looking for,
you know, people who can fill
our creative pot so that--
you know, because a lot of
plates are spinning at once.
So if we're trying
to help out Indiana,
somebody says, I'm creative.
And like, great.
There's a thing
in Ohio, you know,
and you can really help
us like, do this thing.
Or whatever it is.
So, yeah.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
The specificity and the concrete
action there is amazing.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Yeah.
JAIME GREEN: Before I move
on to my next question,
we're going to be opening
it up for audience questions
in a minute.
So if you want to
ask a question,
just go line up behind
one of those microphones
so that we know that
you have a question.
We'll get to that in one second.
But first, in addition
to these very specific,
local, on-the-ground efforts,
you're also doing a lot online.
Through social
media, through video,
can you talk a little
bit about that?
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Yeah and maybe we
should show one of our videos.
So--
JAIME GREEN: What
a fantastic segue.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: What
So we, one of the greatest joys
is to dispel myths in a way
that people really latch on to.
One of the greatest myths
in reproductive health care
is that Plan B and
IUDs are abortions.
There was a Supreme Court
case called Hobby Lobby where
this Christian craft
store, I don't even
know what that means,
[LAUGHTER]
Decided that they
didn't want to disperse
birth control if the birth
control was promoting abortion.
And they listed Plan
B on their list.
And it's like, Plan B does
not, not only does not
promote abortion,
it stops an egg
from actually leaving the
egg holder, scientific term,
[LAUGHTER]
In the first place.
So in order to like, lay this
shit down once and for all,
we're like, let's make a video.
So we decided to make a cartoon.
And we got a Lea DeLaria from
"Orange Is the New Black"
to be the voice of Plan B.
And we'll just roll the,
we'll roll the video.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: You'll
learn a little something.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Sorry, ma'am.
I have to get another
cashier to sell you Plan B.
- Why?
- Because Plan B
causes abortion.
And I don't have
to sell it to you
because abortion goes
against my religious beliefs.
- Wait, It's not an abortion.
And double wait, a cashier
can deny me birth control?
- You are a correct, ma'am.
That is actually the law.
And I don't like it.
Listen up Mr. Cashier.
[SINGING] I'm just a pill.
A kind of birth control pill.
No matter what they
say on Capitol Hill.
Well it's a wrong, wrong story
they keep telling about me.
A strong, strong lie, all
I do is block pregnancy.
I wish they'd listen
to what scientists say.
So at the end of the
day, you can chill.
Drop some facts.
Tell the world, I'm a pill.
- Gosh, Pill.
Preventing an unwanted
pregnancy seems so helpful.
How'd you get so many enemies?
- Well, a lot of
folks like this fella,
got together and decided
that I cause abortions.
But I don't.
I stop ovulation from
happening, preventing
fertilization and pregnancy.
- Wait, a fertilized
egg isn't a pregnancy?
- No.
After an egg is fertilized,
it takes 72 whole hours
for the egg to make its way to
the uterus and implant itself.
That is a pregnancy.
My job is to stop the
egg from ever traveling
to Fallopian Tower,
preventing that pregnancy.
- So life doesn't
being at conception?
- When life begins
is an opinion.
When pregnancy begins
is a scientific fact.
Are you get getting it yet?
- Kind of.
- Well, think of it
like a football game.
The quarterback drops back
and tosses to the receiver
at the 20 yard line.
The fertilization
happens the second
the receiver catches the ball.
Now, we all know the rules.
The fertilized egg still needs
to make it into the end zone
[LAUGHTER]
Before it's a touchdown.
But, if there is
no ball to catch--
- There can never
be a touchdown.
- Now you're getting it!
Doctors say pregnancy doesn't
happen until the touchdown.
So my job is to block that
touchdown from happening.
And I do.
- Wow Plan B!
You're like the Deion Sanders
of preventing pregnancy.
[LAUGHTER]
- Actually, Deion Sanders wishes
he was the Plan B of football.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, I hope that
cleared things up.
But just in case it didn't,
[SINGING] I'm just a pill.
A helpful birth control pill.
No matter what they
say on Capitol Hill.
So now you know my truth,
I'm all about prevention.
If your condom breaks,
I'm here for intervention.
Join me take a stand today
I really hope and not
pray that you will.
Drop some facts.
Tell the world.
I'm a pill.
- Wow, Pill.
Science is fun.
Turns out you prevent more
abortions then anyone I know.
I'd be happy to sell
you to customers.
- That's right.
Prevention is my jam.
Bye now.
- Wait, Pill.
Will I ever see you again?
- Well, let me put it
to you this way, kid.
I'm always here if you need me.
And I'm really safe so you
don't even need a prescription.
- Even if you're a teenager?
- Yeah.
Even if you're a teenager.
Oh, and just one more thing,
I know I'm awesome but please,
always use a condom.
[SINGING] Join me.
Take a stand today.
I really hope and not
pray that you will.
Drop some facts.
Tell the world.
I'm a pill!
[APPLAUSE]
- LPJL shuts down the fake
facts around birth control
and abortion every damn day.
Join us, and help
spread the truth.
[END PLAYBACK]
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Did
you learn something?
[APPLAUSE]
It was really important
for us to make that video.
Especially with Neil
Gorsuch, who is, as you know,
in line to possibly be the
next Supreme Court Justice.
And he is somebody who ruled
in the lower court for Hobby
Lobby, agreeing with
the fake science
that-- so, you know,
so we put it out.
And it's also, for me,
really important the line
about teenagers, you know.
It's good to make
video sometimes
that kids can pass
around to their friends.
And they can know that
I can go get that if I'm
a teen and my condom broke.
That I can go test that out.
Because I think a lot of
times we don't let our teens--
we deny sexuality of teens, and
especially teen girls, so much.
And I think it's important
to be living in the world
where there's not abstinence
and unicorns, in the one
where there's actually sex.
And sometimes
unintended pregnancy.
And so let's like, be
real and help people out.
So, yeah.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
And I think one of the great
things about that video is--
LIZZ WINSTEAD: The
football shooing its sperm?
[LAUGHTER]
The penis?
It's really good.
JAIME GREEN: One of
the other great things,
in addition, because
there are many.
But that's actually my point.
That like, it has that
information for teens
were it's like, hey teens.
You can go get this
over the counter.
And it also has information for
people who are already thinking
and arguing about this.
Like the-- something I haven't
heard before is the distinction
between when does life begin--
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Yes!
JAIME GREEN: Versus when
does pregnancy begin?
Because anyone can say, well,
I think life starts here,
I think it starts there.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Look, sperm move.
That's life.
Is that a person?
You know what I mean?
Like, when life begins
literally is this subjective--
and life begins at conception?
That is not a scientific term.
That's a medical--
I mean, that's a religious term.
You know, fertilization
is conception.
And so it still
needs that, you know.
As we show this video, if you
just figured that out now,
don't worry.
Most people are
like, I had no idea.
It's like, it's OK.
A lot of people didn't.
In fact, we thought Plan
B stopped an implantation
from happening.
But it turns out that's
not what it does.
So there's like, misnomers
around that as well.
So we wanted to make
sure that people
knew that it stops the egg from
actually leaving the fallopian
tube in the first place.
So it was approved because
they thought it might
have stopped implantation.
And here's what's crazy.
The website of Plan B says
that, and it's not right.
So we consulted with
a team of physicians
to actually make
sure it was right.
So I'm like, so
the football thing?
Is it cool if like, it
gets shot out of the thing?
And they're like,
yeah, it's fine.
So it was--
[LAUGHTER]
Like having them help
us write it into plain,
into medical text.
And then having us translate
it into fallopian town
and all this other shit.
[LAUGHTER]
Was kind of fun.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah, well,
because in a lot of ways
the anti-abortion
movement has really
controlled the rhetoric of
how we talk about things.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: 110%.
And that can be incredibly
damaging, incredibly shaming.
And, you know, it's like, things
that our very good friends will
say are sometimes like--
on a larger scale it
can make people wonder.
When they say like, well
no one's for abortion.
You know what?
Except for people
who need an abortion.
You know.
Like, I say often, there
are no good abortions,
there are no bad
abortions, there's just
the abortion that you need.
And I think that we need
to bear that in mind
as somebody is going
through that choice
to terminate a pregnancy.
That lobbing judgment
or saying things like,
that I'm pro-choice,
I'm not pro-abortion.
You know, why is it
that you say that?
By saying that it sounds like
abortion is a dirty thing
that has to happen.
When-- if one in three women
statistically will have
an abortion in her
reproductive lifetime--
it sounds to me like that's
a piece of medical care
that a lot of people
are going to need.
And so for us to put a caveat
or a shaming space on that,
based on this assault of
dis-information medically--
We need to examine that as
people who are advocates
for, you know, full autonomy.
And if you believe that women's
rights are human rights,
one of the first rights that
we should all be defending
is how and if and when
you want to have kids.
And make sure you have full
autonomy over your body.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: That's
what I believe.
[APPLAUSE]
JAIME GREEN: I just entirely
lost my train of thought.
[LAUGHTER]
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Because
you're thinking about that
penis shooting
out that football.
[LAUGHTER]
JAIME GREEN: It's
very distracting.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: I
know, it's true.
JAIME GREEN: One
question, something
that's been in the news lately,
among all the many garbage
fires--
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Yes,
so much garbage fire.
JAIME GREEN: And especially in
the aftermath of the election,
is the question of
whether abortion rights
and reproductive freedom should
be a non-negotiable issue
in the Democratic Party--
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Yes.
JAIME GREEN: --on the left.
If it's-- if you
can be, you know,
on the left and not pro-choice?
I mean, I'm going to ask what
are your thoughts on that?
I think I know what your
thoughts are on that,
but I'd love to hear
you talk about that.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Well I just
wrote a massive piece.
There was an article in
"The New York Times," that
just was in "The New York
Times," where a woman wrote
that there was-- it was
alienating in the women's
movement if you are not an
abortion rights advocate.
And what I say to
that is simple.
You can totally be somebody
who has personal feelings
about abortion.
The bottom line is, we
live in a secular society
where abortion is safer than
having your teeth pulled.
And if you are going to advocate
against a procedure that
is going to literally clear
a path for someone to pursue
their own destiny, then no.
That is problematic for me.
And that is problematic
for a movement as a whole.
If you say you are a woman's
right advocate, or a person
with a uterus
advocate, that means
that you have to actually
put your feelings aside.
Because your feelings are
your personal feelings.
And when you search
your soul, you
are searching your
soul for yourself.
I do not need you to search
your soul and tell me
you've come up with a
solution, medically,
for what I need to do.
That is wrong and that is not
being a feminist and that's not
part of the feminist movement.
It shouldn't be.
So that's how I feel about it.
JAIME GREEN: Do you think that--
LIZZ WINSTEAD: I'm
reading the comments now.
[LAUGHTER]
JAIME GREEN: Do you think
that opposition to abortion
primarily comes from
a religious place?
Or is there something else,
cultural or psychological?
Because people give--
politicians and people
who are anti-abortion
will give lots of reasons.
It's usually religious, I think?
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Well I think
when you hear things like,
life begins at
conception, again,
that's a religious thing.
Yeah, I mean, almost all
the time it's religious.
And the thing that is--
it goes back to what you
said, of the people who
are anti-abortion, who have
driven the narrative to places
where we just let things go.
Junk science.
There is-- like, abortion
causes breast cancer.
Proven it doesn't.
By every medical establishment
that you can find.
That it causes mental illness.
Again, not proven in
any way, shape or form.
Sterility.
No.
People have multiple
abortions, therefore not true.
So those things just lay there.
And on top of that,
we have states where--
Indiana.
Prime example when Mike
Pence was governor.
He de-funded Planned
Parenthood on a state level.
Those Planned
Parenthood went under.
He gave that $4
million every year
that went to Planned
Parenthood to something
called Crisis Pregnancy Centers.
If you're not aware
of what they are,
they're unregulated clinics,
opened up by religious people,
who--
anybody can wander in.
Somebody dressed
up in a lab coat,
who could probably just work at
the Macy's Lancome counter too,
[LAUGHTER]
Gives people this information.
Will give them an
ultrasound that is--
they might fudge how
far along they are.
They may say, yeah, we'll help
you with diapers and cribs.
Just keep coming back.
And then when they're
past the age of being,
the gestational age to have
an abortion, all of a sudden,
they disappear.
They won't give the
person anything.
They're horrible.
And so, in the course of funding
those unregulated centers,
people are being denied care.
And also, in the
case of Indiana,
they had this outbreak of HIV.
87 cases of HIV in
this county in Indiana.
And the Planned
Parenthood clinic
used to be somebody
that would treat
sexually transmitted diseases,
help people with HIV.
And there was no
Planned Parenthood.
So they actually had to
do pop-up clinics when
they had a system in place.
Just because of this.
So I think that
those things are--
for the most part we see
it's a religious argument
because the medical--
every single piece of medicine
around the issue of abortion
bears out to it being
one of the safest things.
One of the-- and
not preventing you
from choosing to have
a family in the future.
So when they start placing these
caveats, especially when it's
waiting periods and
things like that,
and they say it's all
for the woman's, you
know, just to make sure.
When you start laying
things down like,
we need women to wait.
Because we're not sure she's
made the right decision.
When that becomes part of the
norm in our society, that--
if anybody's ever had the
fear of being pregnant
and didn't want to be
or actually has been,
you know from the
second you might
think that you're
pregnant, you're
thinking about it constantly.
Everything about what that
pregnancy means to your life
is thought through
over and over again.
So to require extra time?
Is society saying, we're not
really sure we trust women
to make decisions?
And that goes out of the
abortion arena and goes into,
should we really trust
women to run our company?
You know.
Should we really trust
women to be president?
Would we?
You know, I mean--
So I think those things
are really telling.
And things that we
should fight against,
while they might seem like
it's for the women, it's not.
It's for the control.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
Last call for questions
from the audience.
But in lieu of that,
something I want to ask
is, on the Lady Parts
Justice League website
you have a video
page with a video
for every state in the country.
That's on the Lady
Parts Justice page.
JAIME GREEN: Oh, OK.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Not
the League page.
We have two organizations.
One is a 501c4--
JAIME GREEN: OK, they
have very similar names.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Which is
political, political,
political.
JAIME GREEN: Gotcha.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Yes.
It's sort of like
Planned Parenthood
and Planned Parenthood Action.
JAIME GREEN: Yes.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Right?
One deals with health
care outreach education.
Still swearing and being fun.
That pill video is
outreach education.
And then we have Lady Parts
Justice, which is-- yes.
Has a video for every state.
And you can go there and
learn about the, like, we
call it politicians money.
JAIME GREEN: OK so that's--
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Two
different things.
JAIME GREEN: Political.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Yep.
JAIME GREEN: This one--
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Yes.
JAIME GREEN:
Informational, educational.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Yes, yes.
So our big tour is through
the Lady Parts Justice League.
JAIME GREEN: Gotcha.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Because
we can hit the road,
do outreach, roll up
our sleeves, do it.
JAIME GREEN: Yes.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Go to the Lady
Parts Justice League website.
JAIME GREEN: Yes.
LIZZ WINSTEAD:
Donate to the tour.
[LAUGHTER]
It's awesome.
JAIME GREEN: Something--
LIZZ WINSTEAD: And
see where we are!
Come visit us!
We're in 16 cities.
You probably live
in one of them.
JAIME GREEN: Something
I wanted to ask
for the people in the audience
here who are in New York.
We usually think of in New York
we've got things pretty good,
nice blue state.
Lots of--
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Yeah.
JAIME GREEN: But
what challenges--
LIZZ WINSTEAD: But it's not.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
So what should people
be aware of here?
LIZZ WINSTEAD: In New York
state, funnily enough,
we have not changed our
abortion law since 1970.
We have pre-Roe v. Wade
abortion laws in our state.
And while it feels like it's
blue and it's great here,
and the city abortion access is
pretty accessible, if you live
in another place, if you
live in rural New York,
it's really hard for you
to access any kind of care.
It's-- abortion laws were
set in the criminal code.
So if you have a
fetal anomaly that--
oftentimes when you hear
about those big scary--
they try to scare you with
like, late-term abortion
and why people have them.
And in 99% of those
are because things
don't happen
gestationally in pregnancy
sometimes until the final
trimester of that pregnancy.
And so, really horrible--
life threatening to the woman,
the fetus won't live outside
of the womb, a lot of bad stuff
happens.
And so sometimes you won't
even know those things, right?
In New York, if you hit
24 weeks and discover
that the fetus will, could cause
you death, could die itself,
you can't get an abortion.
There is no life of the
mother, life of the fetus
exception after 24 weeks.
You have to leave the state.
So, yeah.
So that's like a law that is--
JAIME GREEN: And that's
still in place now?
LIZZ WINSTEAD:
That's in place now.
And they're fighting
for, we're fighting
to change that law right now.
But we have a, kind of
conservative, you know,
a lot of conservatives
in Albany.
Some of them are Democrats
who are anti-choice.
So they won't update
these simple, simple laws
that could be fixed.
And add logical exceptions
so people don't die.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: I don't
know, seems smart.
JAIME GREEN: Not dying
seems like a good thing.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Not dying
seems like-- living
seems like a good
alternative to not dying.
I don't know, I'm for that part.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
JAIME GREEN: All right
well, Lizz, thank you.
Thank you so much.
LIZZ WINSTEAD: Thank
you, it was really great.
Thanks for having me.
JAIME GREEN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]